alors c'est une histoire sans fin
puisque apparemment vous avez reçu une
lettre de la mairie mercredi charlie
dans cette lettre vous apprenez que
votre enfant ne peut pas retourner à la
cantine alors que la dette est
apparemment réglé qu'est-ce que ça à
faire alors elle m'a fait envoyer un
courrier par le même policier municipal
qui vous a fait envoyer madame la maire
d'accord daté du 22 reçu le 22 pour une
fois on reçoit bien c'était parfait
d'accord elle ce courrier a stipulé que
en début d'année elle elle fait passer à
un circulaire qui disait que les enfants
des parents qui ne travaillait pas ne
pouvez pas manger à la cantine et que
donc et il fallait que j'évite de le
récupérer sinon c'était les services
sociaux qui viendrait le récupérer donc
il faut que vous trouviez du travail
pour que will alors que rothen et
enfants à la cantine et il sera pas mis
ni aux activités périscolaires oui et
garderie tout ça tout le temps le
périscolaire d'accord vous avez réagi
comment vous avez dit quoi mais je les
prie mal parce que il ya énormément
d'enfants dont les parents ne
travaillent pas qui sont scolarisés qui
sont reçus à la cantine le midi à la
garderie soir et matin j'ai beaucoup de
noms je connais beaucoup de monde quand
même ça va faire un an et demi de chat
[ __ ] ici donc vous pensez que c'est
dirigé contre vous ah oui oui parce que
j'ai été voir quand même la personne de
la cantine moi j'étais la voir elle m'a
dit moi je ne sais pas du tout je vais
pas vous mentir je ne sais pas du tout
j'ai pas les listes mais on est d'accord
alors aujourd'hui on a la chance d'avoir
madame le maire qui est avec nous ce
soir est ce que vous avez pu discuter
toutes les deux depuis cette affaire pas
du tout donc là vous vous retrouvez sur
le plateau c'est vrai que cette histoire
attriste tous monde
madame la maire qu'est qu'est ce que
c'est que ce nouveau rebondissement
racontez nous alors c'est un
rebondissement qui n'est pas unique est
fait pour madame vraiment loin s'en faut
effectivement on a distribué en début
d'année un règlement intérieur à tous
les parents
de l'école leur disant que s'ils ne
travaillaient pas leurs enfants ne
seraient pas pris en activités
périscolaires et à la cantine tous les
parents avaient une date butoir c'est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pour répondre à
ce à 7 à ce règlement intérieur madame
raymond a signé ce règlement intérieur
le 4 septembre où il était clairement
indiqué que si elle ne travaillait pas
son fils ne pourraient pas ses propres à
votre vote républicain parce que je sais
pour ses propres alors pourquoi ses
propres à l'établissement s'est tout
simplement on a une cantine elle est
grande elle peut recevoir environ 150
élèves c'est cet acquis sauf que depuis
la coville on a dû respecter des mesures
réglementaires et faire en sorte que les
enfants soient distanciés de façon à
mettre
les dangers hors d'eux hors de question
donc ça c'est que l'année dernière 6 il
ya des personnes qui sont au pôle emploi
donc leur enfant ne peut pas être à
lakota
c'est sa foi et non c'est sait pas c'est
si c'est pas du tout la mère travaille
pas j'ai pas il peut pas là continue
enfoncé c'est ça le laury's et c'est ça
puisque c'est une mesure il ya été mise
intervient dans des lancements tout
démarre en septembre à la rentrée à la
cantine pour quoi il a été acceptée du
coup parce qu'on n'avait pas encore le
document de madame raymond on l'a et
puis aujourd'hui on a toujours des
documents excuses à machecoul heures le
fameux règlement intérieur qui doit être
signé par les parents qui seraient
passés en fait c'est cette région vous
saviez pas si elle travaille ou pas ça
c'est un détail un e sur le sujet vous
le saviez vous a dit bon le plus
important c'est que la dette soit
éponger et que will hahn repartent à la
cantine là le 14 vous étiez au courant
que j'avais toujours pas trouvé un
travail entre temps non mais je vous
avais pas dit non ouija ne reviendra pas
parce que je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui si je vous je vous dis moi
ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui on a des
mesures sanitaires à respecter ce
règlement c'est un règlement de cette
année l'année dernière on a pu avoir
tous les ans parce qu'on a délocalisé la
cantine à la salle des fêtes donc ça
nous a permis d'avoir tous les enfants
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas avoir tous
les deux sont nés de la cantine ans
c'est légal pas du tout alors la
question c'est est-ce que c'est légal
alors gilles verdez ben non excusez moi
madame erreurs mais le défenseur des
droits s'est auto saisie du dossier en
france la règle c'est que c'est
l'intérêt de l'enfant qui prime et là
vous privez unilatéralement un enfant de
cantine madame excusez moi vous êtes en
infraction je ne ne prive pas même si un
règlement intérieur on n'a pas le droit
de faire un règlement intérieur on n'a
pas droit inscrivait un enfant de
cantine en france unilatéralement donc
on est bien d'accord sur de toutes les
façons c'est des recommandations ou du
défenseur des droits ce ne sont pas une
règle légale si vous voulez qui permet
de ne pas garder des enfants à la
cantine à partir du moment où nous on a
mis un règlement intérieur que il ya une
raison de réglementations sanitaires
la maman a signé ce règlement donc elle
sait très bien qu'elle ne peut pas
mettre son enfant la cantine voilà
d'accord mais c'est est ce que c est ce
que c'est dirigée envers les anglais
parce que c'est se sait ce qu'elle veut
dire absents que vous avez voilà une
inimitié envers charlie qui a que le
mien yara qui a pas été mangé à la
cantine est allégée par une photo du
parking il enfin l'âme et 10 par an
parce qu'il soit saisir d'autres l'asca
d'autres cas parce que donc tous les
enfants qui sont dans votre continent
ont des parents qui travaillent mais
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas répondu au
règlement intérieur et au questionnaire
au jour d'aujourd'hui je ne connais pas
tous les parents qui travaillent ou qui
ne travaillent pas en l'occurrence je
sais que madame vraiment ne travaille
pas il ya d'autres parents qui ne
laissera alors ses cadres à la cantine
les parents qui ont toujours pas payer
la dette qui n'ont même pas mis
d'échéancier en place qui ne travaillent
pas et leur gamin mangent à la cantine
c'est vous qui le dites et moi c'est
vous moi j'ai des noms des mac au pain
et à l'eau bah oui ils ont tous parents
et moi ça me choque que l'école qui est
un lieu où on est censé tous ces beaux
met en avant à ce point les inégalités
en allant jusqu à humilier une mère et
son fils et on lui demande de lui
demander de rendre publiquement des
comptes sur sa vie privée ses
difficultés financières pourquoi est-ce
qu'on rend pas la cantine gratuite pour
toutes les familles en difficulté comme
cela est évoqué pour une fois de plus
bel accueil aux blacks
alors je suis complètement d'accord avec
toi sur le début de ta phrase après la
tuerie dans un truc qui n'allait pas
c'est passé les premiers milles c'est
une circonscription non mais là
guillaume là sinon la
madame vous êtes dans un palais en fait
c'est à cause de la coved pour qu'ils
aient des problèmes de l'année dernière
ce règlement mais rien n'était pas mis
en place que d'octobre là apparemment
dans les régions de ton est financée à
50 et moins ils vont ils vont libérer et
ouvrir notamment de primaire et de donc
ira plus problème le 2 octobre alors à
partir du moment où il y aura plus de
réglementation et on va mettre quatre
enfants à une table donc il pourra
revenir donc à priori tous les enfants
pour en revenir pas spécifiquement lui
c'est à dire aujourd'hui on n'est pas en
capacité de recevoir tous les enfants et
on a fait effectivement une sélection
arbitraire en disant oui mais une
sélection arbitraire qu'on ne
privilégier pas à la cantine les enfants
dont les parents ne travaillais pas ça
me semblait tout à fait logique pour un
grand nombre je suis désolé moi je suis
peut-être mais je ne vois pas ce qu'il
ya de choquant de privilégier les
enfants dont les parents sont les deux
ou travail ne peuvent pas prendre leurs
enfants bâtiment où il faut bien faire
une priorité partout il n'y a pas de
place pour tout le monde les parents qui
travaillent valeur en fonds sont
prioritaires pour la cantine ont trahis
pas moi je sais pas mais moi je vois pas
qu'est ce qui est choquant qu'une seule
enfant très milliers de ma vie qu'est ce
qui nous empêche de prendre votre enfant
à midi mais rien
elle a peut-être envie de rester avec
ses épaules à la cantine non c'est
exactement ça c'est pas moi oui je sais
ça fait monter à lui il a envie d'aller
sur et c'est pas parce que ma copine et
les parents qui travaillent et dont les
enfants peuvent pas les cantines ils ont
aussi en droit de se dire non mais
attendez pour moi c'est un sol humide
pourquoi on prends pas mon enfant alors
que je fais l'effort de payer la cantine
c'est
madame sélection arbitraire vous avez
dit mme excusez moi le maire a des
pouvoirs mais pas celui-là un maire n'a
pas pouvoir de faire sélection
arbitraire mais je ne forçons pas que le
préfet mme interviendrez chez le
sous-préfet retire ses saisines sous
préfet alors sa réponse je la garde pour
moi non ah bah si c'est sa réponse par
contre vous pouvez l'interrogé vous
l'appelez soirée verrait sa position par
rapport à ça ne peut pas la donne et ne
veut pas la double peut pas la donner
mais j'ai saisi le sous préfet et je
vais saisir le tribunal administratif
pour savoir quelles sont mes entre
guillemets mais droit par rapport à
cette assemblée wil wheaton il est il
doit être hyper triste de cette décision
donc la version parce que lui
s'attendait que du moment où la dette
était terrible en règle et d'ailleurs on
vous remercie et qui pourrait reprendre
les mois je lui ai dit assez bon oui
c'est ça il a alors aujourd'hui j'ai
reçu un email tu peux repartir à la
cantine à partir de jeudi puisque
c'était mercredi non non c'était le
mardi d'accord j'essaie puis elle a
ensuite acquis cette affaire qui tombe
et b ensuite le mercredi le policier qui
vient frapper à ma porte pour me faire
signer à chelsea soit par le coup les
courriers donc on a aimé le faire avait
bien fait on l'avait fait fort vers
l'avenir et hot sinon mais vous savez
c'est par les factures à nyala vous les
avez reçu gdg des les accusés de
réception bana bana vers la
cantine a été réglée quand est ce que le
petit willan pourra retourner à la
comptine 6 à partir du moment tous les
enfants tous les enfants pourront
éventuellement or il ya d'autres non
mais ce cas d'autres enfants qui sont
dans le cas de oui la boxe j'ai
l'impression que non mais bien sûr que
si bien sûr que s'il ya plein d'enfants
je vous dis que c'est bon tu étais moi
je me pose la question madame raymond a
reçu un règlement intérieur vous êtes
bien d'accord et les autres aussi vous
l'avez pas les autres aussi donc il
l'avait signé oui et c'est donc que vous
acceptiez les termes de ce revendeur
vous la voulez mais ses fans et prénom
l'adresse 40 fois c'est facile oui mais
seuls les jouets parents du couple qui
vous est si vous me l'avez ccim la
sicile est gelée avec moi quand on lui
demande les papiers soient pas lui
laisser mais attendez koné série
quotidien le matériau est la part des
choses incroyables dedans donc vous le
signe et vous amener pas très longue
c'est un côté paul hayez qu'il n'est pas
très long à l'irna madame la maire
avouez quand même que moralement c'est
choquant et inadmissible de priver un
enfant de sa cantine et de ses copains
ça déjà c'est une chose en plus et pas
légal vous allez avoir les défenseurs
des droits sur le dos j'ai répondu non
mais vous allez avoir des problèmes
parce que c'est pas légal ce que vous
faites ne doit pas exclure un enfant
comme ça qu'il est payé ou qu'il ait pas
payées on en a déjà parlé ici donc
moralement c'est honteux moi je serais
très gêné à votre place franchement moi
c'est d'être une solution c'est enfin je
veux dire ma carrière
la question bernard la question dans la
llc la question que tout les
téléspectateurs se passer de 10 à vous
imposer un cas de conscience ne rien
vous avez vous avez culpabiliser prendre
cette décision
donc je me prendra version de le oui
mais je les jeux les pas exclue oui j'ai
donné la possibilité aux parents qui
travaillent de laisser leurs enfants à
l'école et à ceux qui ne travaillent pas
de le reprendre de les reprendre parce
que je ne peux pas tous les héberger en
même temps dans les conditions
sanitaires qui sont mises en vigueur ce
qui serait très préjudiciable pour
l'ensemble des enfants c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je ferme la cantine et
ceux qui respectent les règles seraient
tout à fait pénalisé par cette histoire
lui voilà quelque chose ah oui je
voulais savoir alors pourquoi lorsque
vous avez fait raccompagner à pour
l'histoire des impayés il n'y avait pas
comme moi en impayés pourquoi c'était
seulement le mien qui a été raccompagné
aucun autre enfant n'a été raccompagnées
et là maintenant pour l'interdiction de
la cantine c'est seulement le mien aussi
pourquoi si ce n'est pas visé c'est quoi
ton l'émirat s'est pas le goût mais
absolument pas madame je vous rappelle
l'attitude que vous avez eue au
téléphone avec moi on m'avait l'avons
mal déneigées m'avait bien sûr mais
j'avais envie de sénat eut le temps de
vous menaciez oui je veux n'a cessé de
ne pas payer la cantine la l'accès aux
tribunes installées qu un rouge-gorge
hystérique j'avais au téléphone ça
suffit ça suffit mais je les appelle moi
j'ai les factures détaillées on va voir
qui appelait qu'ils aient le temps de au
téléphone vous avez aimé vous avez
raison tu pouvais vous êtes vous êtes
tout à fait dans votre étonnement elle
dans votre jeu pouvait écouter un audio
si c'était possible il dure quarante
secondes oui c'est ma soeur la mère qui
laisse un message vocal à ma copine
parce qu'elle n'a pas reçu le règlement
et qui explique que ce que le petit va
manger à midi du coup sinon ils ont là
ce message audio j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un tribunal
surtout ça ne concerne pas que madame
raymond oui mais ça vous fera tourner ça
ne concerne pas madame vraiment d'accord
ça concerne une autre personne ça
concerne une autre personne oui et donc
c'est quoi c'est une gestion du coup
c'est la même question ça même éclora il
faudrait que vous mettiez le téléphone
vraiment devant votre quoi
n'entend pas bien pas n'entend pas bien
sûr les vraiment je suis désolé écoutez
la fin j'ai simplement
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est moins acquise non c'est moi
qui le dit c'est moi oui mais vous savez
ce que ça vous savez ce que c'est et
vous le savez c'est le minimum
il a quatre ans il n'a pas dit s'il
avait mangé on sait pas dupes non mais
ça c'est bon c'est bon score minimal
juste donner pour essayer de trouver on
essaie de trouver des solutions ici un
choc tu veux le nouveau julien courbet
non mais c'est vrai juste sur les et
madame la maire est ce que le dr il va
pouvoir retourner à la cantine ou pas
je ne sais pas où ils les verront là dit
pas si les maisons relevé le dr
il avait retrouvé les décisions
gouvernementales
donc c'est la danse et le 4 octobre
d'ailleurs 4 mai c'est le 2 octobre un
samedi c'est j'ai la trouille aux jeux a
dit j'attends d'avoir les décisions
gouvernementales mais leur vessie voilà
mes six coptes comme prévu le 4 octobre
les décisions vont dans le bon sens est
ce qu'il y retournera la commune où les
enfants donc donc ils ont ri dan aussi
qui sait bien sûr tous les enfants qu'en
soirée mais par contre moi je me pose
une question ou récupérer un de vos
enfants à midi pourquoi vous récupérez
pas l'autre ce que vous êtes c'est
l'école privée c'est onéreuse déjà de
battre sans la cantine c'est onéreux
donc c'était un choix c'est pas du tout
les mêmes horaires c'est 11h10 c'est
donc parce que je veux avec mes enfants
vont à la wii willan jeunes à la carène
unis va pas c'est comme ça en fait à
écouter en tout cas on espère vraiment
étonnés nous au courant on espère que le
4 octobre willan sera alors bien sûr
penser que l'on pensait que
madame vraiment arrêter de passer pour
une victime vous n'êtes absolument pas
victimes non c'est mon fils c'est vous
qui l'avez rendu victimes en médiatisant
bien sûr là ce qui nous manque non mais
ils vont les vous allez vous aimez ça
vous aimez ça madame la maire le 4
octobre il sera là continue ou pas si si
j'ai les dents mesures si les ondes pour
la dentelle this was issued des enfants
mais madame la merde il mesure le 4
octobre ce sera bon donc s qui sera là
continue quatre automates ou les enfants
qui sont concernés par le règlement
intérieur donc oui la donne sera à
continuer dans quatre hôpitaux comme
tous les autres d'enfin donc il y sera
ben oui pourquoi il y serait pas ma part
y faire de ce débat continue comme ça
madame raymond pourra vous envoyer de
nouveau un courrier pour pouvoir faire
site web bien moi j'ai pas besoin
d'envoyer des courriers en face il
espère à sion où vous disiez d'autres
réseaux où il a oeuvré à la lance
finalement ce n'est pas vrai d'autres
raisons oui ou alors on verra le 4e but
dans son cas on attend ça mais un
signalement a manqué ce cas qu'est-ce
qu'un des fils je voulais dire mais en
fait c'est c'est un club parce qu'en
fait la conclusion c'est les gens qui
enchaîne deux boulots pour pouvoir payer
la cantine de ses enfants en fait c'est
des abrutis en fait voilà non mais c'est
ça il ya des gens ils se tuent au boulot
et donc la conclusion c'est quoi vous
travaillez pas d'ici le 4 octobre vous
aurez pas trouvée entre temps vous avez
sénat ip ngn importe que je travaille et
en plus c'est une carrière plici
d'illégal c'est en bien de ça au bout
d'un moment l'école la cantine et le
périscolaire c'est un truc où il faut
payer et tout le monde doit jouer le jeu
on ne peut pas on peut pas juste
utiliser le système est pas payé vous
voyez pas ce qu'il achetait alors
aujourd'hui on parle plus de la dette
grâce à cyril c'est vrai que oui grâce à
c il y assure c'est pas que le petit ne
peut pas aller à l'école parce qu'à la
rigueur il a du temps vous enfin vous
avez du temps vous pouvez être ensemble
l'humiliation ces deux publiquement
nationalement dans cette émission à
forte audience montrez votre petit parce
qu'à l'adolescence c'est ce qu'on va
dire ben ouais ma mère elle est venue
elle m'a affiché parce qu'en fait on n'a
pas fait ça va me demander son
consentement le jour
sur ce que vos débats
[Musique]
fine un peu d'humanité cia et placer
20 juillet que ça l'amusait faudrait pas
la cantine elle est obligée est la clef
de venir là
il ya 150 enfants si les 150 enfants
gilles font comme ça c'est comme ça que
la france n'a pas il ya des gens qui se
tuent au goulot qui enchaîne deux jobs
pour toi feu qui ne bossent pas bien ici
on éponge les dettes et apprendre c'est
encore une canne à pêche ce que vous
allez faire avec ses 30000 euros
il ya des promesses de dos à hauteur de
30 mille euros
les
u6 à la conclusion que notre litige et
de ma ville a fait une cagnotte ya eu 80
euros je lui ai demandé de rentrer à
tout le monde large accord ya pas eu de
30 millions là vous avez touché aucune
d'accord isabelle avait l'air d'accord
avec delphine moi je trouve que d'idées
le film très logique et je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de parents qui effectivement
se crève pour régler la cantine parce
que c'est leur priorité se disent c'est
quand même un peu creux voir moi je veux
dire juste l'histoire on peut être
d'accord les autres l'important c'est
vraiment c'est un petit oui la
formulation et on voit là on voit que là
le pauvre là il doit vivre des moments
compliqués
c'est de prendre un job et de payer les
dettes comme la caf au conte
moi ça arrive et
s'il a envie d'être femme au foyer mère
au foyer enfin ça quand je suis en fait
pas tout seul c'est la bonne la mairie
pour les femmes au foyer je trouve en
ont mais il aime la mer dégradant ça
veut dire jouer votre manager vous dis
pas les juin quand il avait à ce
moment-là anticipé on paie selon m josé
montilla dans la vie et on laisse couler
les bêtes se vit que mon travail dans
l'aride gêné par vous voyez jamais la
cantine dont les dettes ont même s'il
vous plaît merci je vais le chrome os le
maire cyril très bien il a épongé les
dettes c'est magnifique à l'époque
valorisation je ferai plus jamais c'est
fini maintenant je pense que ça lui a
servi ne sont pas j'imagine que vous
allez payer rentrer dans les clous que
c'était après c'est un nouveau
rebondissement qui moi me semble
complètement discriminatoire pour les
mamans au foyer mayer 6-1 sur elle mais
c'est seulement
c'est
pas ça le sujet on verra en tout cas le
4 octobre sur les six wi lan est à la
cantine ont battu m et avec le débat et
est intéressant il ya une variante c'est
énormément de réactions